we're in here with Brickell we just met
up with zerka today we're going to be
saving feminists from the billionaire
satanic mindset that they've all adopted
all of them are lovely ladies what do
you think's a bigger problem toxic
masculinity or toxic femininity
masculinity what is toxic masculinity
um are you a teenager I'm 24. expired
are men and women equal that's fair for
me I think men are better than women I
think that comparisons are horrible I
think everyone is equal women have
trouble driving like with a car yeah
but we are not talking about abilities
if we talk about ability it's okay maybe
man is better than women and Engineering
philosophy poetry art
and I'm I think I'm intelligent you are
but most women are not you're the
exception I don't think so everybody is
unique are men and women equal in what
way physical are we are we physically
the same no or who's better drivers men
or women
what are the statistics yeah you tell me
have you noticed there's been thousands
and thousands of years and there's still
not even one female genius
what's up who's better like you know
Albert Einstein Arthur schofenauer Niche
Plato Aristotle but like for the female
side it grows up there's Rosa Parks
who do you guys have it's a really
pedantic question who who was more
influential Martin Luther King or George
Floyd
and fixing racism because they both
helped fix it for the better you know
Floyd was good when he wasn't beating up
a pregnant lady right who do you think's
a better driver men or women
you don't want to say it on YouTube do
you I don't know you don't know it's
difficult women women you think women
are better jobs are you a feminist yeah
yeah you're a feminist I'm a little bit
of a feminist just a little bit can men
become women no no where are you from
Austria is there transgender stuff in
Austria not a lot I would say I've never
met one you've never met a transgender
person oh wow who ages better men or
women men men women women women you
think women get the older they get the
better looking they get yes do you think
so yeah women age like sardines age like
milk black don't crack we don't crack
you think a 45 year old woman can
compete with a 21 year old bad little
[__] the pants on the tits okay okay
one you won are you ladies feminist yes
yeah you are yes are men and women equal
they should be they should be yes who's
who's a better driver men or women I
consider myself a good driver but my dad
is the best driver I know so my dad what
do you think are you a feminist not
really sorry why aren't you a feminist
like because I don't think that men and
women it depends I'm not gonna say we're
not equal but I think that men should be
masculine and women should be in tune
with their feminine side what do you
think of that yeah sounds pretty good
what do you think pretty base could you
hear them I think the only thing women
are what the [__]
they are better at some things than men
like an Asian woman can kill so many
people on the road
right like they're really good at like
you know what I'm saying
kill streak kill streak why specifically
Asian
like this yo what the [__] slow down
[__] it's crazy so you did it in Asia
and I didn't know how to drive can you
drive yes
are you guys like better drivers than
white women that doesn't matter race
doesn't matter he just started taking it
you know you know like Andrew take all
them you like Andrew Tate I really isn't
he like really irrelevant to me oh I
know Andrew said yeah he loves Andrew
Tate I love him yeah
I helped him organize the girls in
Romania I'm just like him but I have
hair and I'm not a homosexual
how do you know him yeah wait are you
American Income
he goes yeah yeah that's me is it you
actually yeah you want a picture with
them here let's take let's get a picture
take a picture with the girls I took a
picture with the fin there you go
bro what that's tough G [__] right there
he's being a fans huh
well she like she goes circus nice like
I know you and she's like the
conversation circus like
if you had to be One race other than
yours what would you be uh Saudi Arabia
Arabs you'd be Arabic yeah I pick Arabic
I would be black why would you pick
black because
they just have they're just bad at
building muscle you know so yeah
downstairs jeans it's also because
um back in Africa they had like a a
disease from the mosquito what's it
called Valeria malaria yeah yeah and
like the the people who didn't have the
the muscle building genetic they all
died out and the ones that did they
lasted so you know not why black people
are so so much stronger so Jags because
they got that genetic because they know
that yeah yeah it's pretty bad yeah I'm
not from Africa by the way I'm from
America what do you guys think of
feminism um I think uh you're a male
feminist no I'm not uh-uh why not
hi what's up you don't know me uh yes I
do what kind of yes possibly I'm really
bad with names and whatever
um I'm gonna go back to my condo okay
you guys know each other yeah we do
through my free through here
yeah yeah yeah one night yeah
why do you think all women neuter their
dogs right away she's not neutered oh no
no like like most women is that facts
women are evil is what we're getting oh
because okay do you really want to be
cleaning up period blood on your [__]
couches all the time yeah you're a funny
story they bleed for like a month
straight what's the baby's name his name
is Dexter he's Dexter on Kick we're on
kicks
nuts and he's sort of bleeding
everywhere at the party
that's Corona oh careful he's gonna try
to bite your nuts I got a cup don't
worry who's smarter men or women it
depends on what subject like like what
are what are women smarter at I feel
like Women are Smarter at like life
skills
[Applause]
exactly men are a lot more intelligent
with making business decisions because
less emotions are involved harder than
women right guys no why do you think so
many modern women get so offended like
they won't even accept that women are
emotional like that's like that's like
an emotional as [__] but why don't the
girls accept it why can't they all be
like you really I think it's just like
power to the women I mean I get it but
at the same time I'm like we are
emotional we carry babies like we have
hormones like they're not a bad thing
it's not a bad thing there's a purpose
for like women and like I think it's a
little overplayed that like okay like
they want we want to be like boss
[__] and like run companies and [__]
like that but then whenever somebody
comes at us with like an issue we like
deteriorate or like somebody criticizes
a girl for something it's like oh they
take it a lot harder than like a guy
sometimes you just I feel like women
don't have thick there's less women that
have thick skin compared to men all
right if you had a daughter would you
rather have her date Martin Luther King
or George Floyd Martin Luther King why
is that they're both black political
activists like I feel like Martin Luther
King's not a [__] political activist
yes she is bro he fixed racism bro
porn star no you're tripping right now
yeah he even made a tweet about trans
people saying like trans people are
[__] weird ah bro no George Floyd
supports that we added we added lines on
the flag I'm gonna say Martin Luther
King had a I feel like he had a larger
impact on like Society compared I mean
George Floyd did have a large impact but
I mean he's a hero a bad impact
everything was fake about that whole
case I plead the fifth I mean it's true
you know it's true because [__] what
did what did George Floyd do for America
[__] nothing dog I'm trying to learn
how do I get girls so I'm asking girls
what do I do what's the most important
things in a guy confidence confidence
are men allowed to cry sure you think
men can cry Circa do you think men can
cry in a relationship yeah but it's gay
like it'll turn the woman off uh not in
the beginning later they're like like
circumstances for when he could cry like
let's say you get a flat tire and it's
just like it's too much if the guy gets
to eat cries with flat tire yeah like
women do that all the time or what if he
can't change a flat tire what if he's
asking you if he's asking me to change
his time higher yeah no like we're equal
aren't men and women equal well I don't
know how to change a tire I'll call
someone to change my attire so but do
you expect your man to do it or if he
doesn't know it's no big deal if he
doesn't know he can call someone okay if
you're like out in public and like let's
say some guy gives you one of these do
you expect your man to square up right
away or like what if he what if he
looked at you and was like baby what do
I do he's asking me what to do now yeah
no no I don't think he should like punch
someone out but he should tell them off
well it depends if it's a big black guy
you're not gonna fight a big black guy
all right look at that you don't want to
fight this guy no
I'll bite you bro bro
straight out of Dade County Florida we
are Miami I would like to welcome you
give me some girl advice how do I get
girls
smile give him a smile put you on your
teeth yeah give him one of these yeah
good looking guys always get girls
everybody out enjoy yourself
and enjoy it and have a safe trip back
Miami day baby
get out get out get out get out get out
you see that she's trying to attacks me
totally crazy man she's trying to get
money off me she's like oh I know who
you are oh I got people who want to jump
you blah blah blah they're coming here
to meet you so come [__] so come what
do you think about feminism I mean we
believe whatever we want to believe
right I don't really support it though
why not what do you not think men and
women are equal they are equal but I
mean there's not one's not greater than
the other correct don't you think women
suck at everything what are they better
at than men I mean men are greater
though let's just be honest yeah but
like but 99 better or 99.9 110 there you
go so you're not into this feminism
stuff no if you're ugly as a guy what do
you do honestly there's only one thing
you can do max out status and um Network
so basically become a millionaire but
chill with Club promoters meeting people
and uh you can work on your looks and
stuff but you're saying ugly as [__]
right yeah unfortunately you gotta stick
to a lot smaller pool of women you know
like you can't you're not gonna be a
Logan Paul like yeah I mean that guy
used to bang a lot right now he's
married total cuck by the way like dude
are you gonna get married yeah if I go
to a third world country like Colombia
and I get like a virgin yeah no oh [__]
it's fresh just a little bit
all right the top G wouldn't do this for
you right would Andrew take be watching
a black man trying to say I'm racist
they're trying to say a black man's
Lambo bro you know this is
I don't hate black people I just don't
like them what so what do you think what
like to some extent it is just a numbers
game they gotta have a boyfriend if you
want to sleep with one woman that
weekend get 10 phone numbers if you get
one phone number and she's very nice
with you and kissing you
she's not gonna text you at 3am what I
learned in the clubs is 10 numbers
equals one [__] it's always abundance
always and just like Byron says when you
have girls in line I forget they're
saying but it's basically they behave
correct when you have 10 other [__]
okay right and really why social because
it's going to be competition like they
don't want to be the one no it's anxiety
it's anxiety again if Sony has 10 girls
around him he's not that desperate
but ladies come here I'm famous let's
get on YouTube real quick real quick
okay well
you look very mid hey I'm Petty I'm
Petty okay I'm not used to rejection
held from Mount pretorius I know in two
years she's gonna hit the wall and
expire so I'm I'm the bread probably a
year and a half bro yeah who ages better
men or women men bro yeah
black guys keep it the realest that's
what I've always noticed I do a lot of
these yeah yeah you guys don't play
around
in jail today I don't know what that's
got to do with me oh no that might be
the other side it's our community
I'm a racist no you're not try to be for
the cloud I know it's all good if you're
around social proof a bunch of women oh
this guy is not gonna strangle me to
death because they have death anxiety a
man can overpower them but that's why if
you have a Ferrari get in their anxiety
shoots up who are you even if you're in
a Ferrari right even if it's a spider
like get in so now when you have social
proof he's not desperate I'll be alone
with him in his crib in his hotel if
you're her moderator with no women
around you do you really think she'll
let you be alone with her she's gonna
say it's his first time around a
beautiful woman what is this moderator
gonna do but if she's berserk oh she's
gonna be like what's Zircon gonna do
kick me out and call another [__]
social proof lowers their anxiety that's
why they love players right going out
with girls is the same thing yeah it
makes perfect sense and if you go out
with girls they can't be girls like I
recommend guys go out with girls but if
you look like really good looking
they'll get jealous and start [__]
blocking Bill oh they might get you a
bunch of girls week two they start [__]
blocking and you won't notice they're
[__] blocking they'll be so good at it
if you feel one of them has a crush on
you don't go out with her at all
never and they called block like in a
way where it's like they make the girl
think that you've dated her before right
so if you hooked up with a girl she
presents herself as her your ex then the
other girl doesn't want you as much
women ruin everything women ruin
everything that's what I took out of
this it is funny at the end of the day
it's like you just put together words in
the English vocabulary and it leads to a
mouth around your dick like when you
think about it like that because they're
all mental remember men are mechanical
so you don't have to be mentally
stimulated to Banger unless you're like
me where I really want to know who she
is first yeah but men can just bang a
stranger women need to be mentally and
then physically around okay so oh I'm so
so you can see me I'm rich my name is
John zurco what is your name
Barbara okay Barbara okay Barbara we
want to know what's the most attractive
thing a man can say in the mental like
why how can I tickle your Mentos I mean
how can you tickle my man so like what
if I had to say something to pick you up
what do you want me to how do you want
me to pick you up
what problems in your life can I solve
I think that's how you get women so you
get the money guy I'm giving you free
tricks okay honest honest answer what
problems can I yeah I know right what
problems can I solve go
I'm quit this job I'm rich yeah I have a
few bills to pay I mean what do you mean
what kind of if you quit this job right
now we start dating today you're crazy
you know who he is no I don't have
social media and I'm I'm actually chill
I do a bunch of globes for the videos
but I'm so chill when you're in Miami
yeah I even travel I'll do it in
Kentucky with you right do you do blog
so when we're laying down at home at the
hotel before we make out I'm very chill
but when we do these videos oh what's
happening but when we do these videos
I'm very intense if you notice I'm like
I just did a rip yeah I see you feel it
I feel it great meeting you Barbara
great meeting you too oh my god
um I'm sweating it's been a long day
we're here with Barbara and sunny fast
and I just [__] the game up peace
[Music]
gone
yeah
number secured